okay thank you i think we
will start with the second talk of today
so we're gonna we have a pleasure of
having basic academy that's gonna talk
about marginal treatment effect with
misclassified treatment you have 40
minutes thank you thank you smile thank
you
uh for inviting me to
this workshop i'm having a
great week so far thank you thomas and
all the organizers
so
yeah um
iowa state university
so in the summer i'm going to join the
university of north carolina
so this is a joint work with uh santiago
cereza who is now a
an assistant professor at thought in
uruguay
and kenya hongban will be on the market
next year and he's doing well so
marginal treatment defect with
misclassified treatment
so i will start with this
statement from
a paper and restart by a colleague of
mine drunk rider
he says that even the homogeneous
treatment the first framework
measurement error in binary regressors
will result in severe identification
deterioration of regression coefficients
okay even if you take the simple linear
als regression
and then the
treatment variable is binary
and mismeasured
you will lose identification of the
coefficient
okay and the problem is severe severe in
the treatment effects where you have
heterogeneity in the effects
okay
so i'm going to consider
the iv model okay
so in this literature the first paper to
really investigate the consequences of
measurement and treatment variable
when we allow for heterogeneity is the
paper by itaquiaora from uc davis
he's the first to provide bounds on the
local average treatment effect
also called the complier average causal
effects in statistics
so
there is the this paper by
uh zhang and deng
where the derived bond on the late
in the binary iv model where the all the
outcome variable the treatment variable
and
the instrument the all binary
but they consider the framework with
non-differential measurement errors
here i'm going to allow for differential
differential measurement errors okay
and we're going to look at a different
object called the marginal treatment
effect i'm going to i'm going to
introduce that object
okay what we do we derive bound
on these objects
okay under the same set of assumptions
that takoya ura has in his paper
and we showed that
if you
look at the legs in our framework we're
good we're going to show that we get
tighter bounce on the same object that
he look at
i'm going to show where the improvement
comes from
and more importantly we're going to show
that the bonds that we get
can identify the sign of the emotional
treatment effect locally
okay
so usually one criticism of the bounds
is that they don't
they are not informative right here we
can show that
always we can get
designed locally i will explain what i
mean locally but
delayed
is a form of integral aggregation of
modular treatment effect so even though
you can be able to sign
the empty for local
values of the
instrument when you aggregate them you
may lose the sign oh that's why when you
look at the late you may not be able to
see what is the sign of the late but for
the modular treatment effect you can
tell the sign
okay
so i'm going to show some illustrations
through
numerical
uh and empirical
design okay
questions
so
this is the model so we're going to
spend a lot of time on this slide to
make sure that we understand what we're
going to we're doing
so
i observe an outcome variable y
okay
and then i have a treatment variable
this term
which is not observed
but instead i observe d
so you can think of y
as
your earnings or wage and they being
whether you have a college degree or not
okay
so when in the survey i ask you
do you have a college degree you tell me
yes or not right i have no way to check
whether what you're telling me is
the truth okay
you can just miss reports even if at
some point you drop out from college
you tell me that you get the correct
degree
so this style would be the true
okay indicator for college degree
and this is what you report to me what
you tell me
in the data i see why your earnings
a cd
and then we're going to assume
that
the decision to go to college
is a cost benefits
decision you look at your course which
will be v
and you look at your benefits of going
to college which will be this function
pc
so when your cost is less than or equal
to the benefits then you make the
decision to go that will be an
assumption here
yes
[Applause]
yes yes good question
so this
the decision is just such that when v is
less than this pc
this time is equal to one otherwise this
star is equal to zero
now
the epsilon
is
the misclassification the misreporting
indicator for misreporting okay
so
when epsilon is equal to one then i see
d equal to d star
d equal to one minus d star
and when epsilon is equal to zero
meaning that there is no misreporting
there is no error
measurement error then d is equal to d
star
so this representation here
is not an assumption
when you take any two binary variables
you can always write down this
representation
okay
so now the assumption
that you're talking about whether
epsilon is independent of this star
no we're not going to require that
okay but we're going to discuss
all the scenarios so we're going to look
at the case when epsilon is independent
of this star and we're also going to
look at the case when epsilon is not
independent of this type
okay
so in this literature when you have
binary treatment variable it is well
known that the measurement error can
only be non-classical in the sense that
the measurement error cannot be
independent of the true treatment
and that's happening here when you look
at d
you can write this as equal to d star
plus 1 minus 2 times d star times
epsilon then the measurement error is
this
1 minus 2 times d star times epsilon
so as you see this measurement error is
negatively correlated with this star in
that well understood in the literature
okay
so the object of interest would be
the expected value
of y1 minus y0 given
this value the a value of v
v is the unobserved variables that
drives the selection into treatment
okay
so
if you think of it
like in the late framework you can think
of the v here
the unobserved variables that drive the
compliance type the compliance status
okay
whether you are a complier
and always take away the fire right
now
why would this object be of interest
if you look at the set the setting of
the
late the compliance setting
right
we have these
three variables here
okay assume that my instruments here dbc
i will talk about that soon is binary
then
assume that the pc p0 p1 here
in the standard local average treatment
effect setting
this population will be
a set of compliers
okay so when you try to identify the
late you are looking at these people
here you have the always takers
then you have the navy takers here
okay
now
within the set of compliers
it's possible that some people have
positive effect
some people have negative effects and
even some people have zero effects
if you look at the late
you may not detect that
but if you look at the modular treatment
effect
you may see this heterogeneity
that otherwise you will not get through
this local average treatment effect
questions
what is the symbol
the p of c here
is what i call the benefit function but
in the late framework will be just the
propensity score the probability of
getting treated
yes
so the p of z
if you think about it if you have the
instrument is valid right and they say
that it's independent of v and y one y
zero
the probability of getting treated
if we normalize the distribution of the
v to be uniform will be equal to the pc
okay
questions
yeah i have a question so are you are
you going to be implicitly conditioning
on values of b that designate compliers
so that your vertical treatment effect
is equivalent to
late or are you going to be
extrapolating to always takers and never
takers yes that's that's a good question
so
that
this is the case where you have a binary
instrument but now when you have the
continuous instrument
then you can define
let's say you take c1
and z2
you can define the compression
with regard to this pair right
and then for late you can be able to get
this but with the marginal due to defect
with respect to this
pair i will be able to say something
about a value here
when i have a continuous instrument so
you can decide to have multiple legs
based on the pairs that you consider
but if you look at the modular treatment
required for something outside here it's
possible that you identify things
and that's also one advantage of looking
at the modular treatment event
okay
questions
okay so
i'm going to show you why
the modular treatment defect is also
important i just introduced that through
this explanation but you can get all the
other parameters
through the modular treatment effects
once you have the modular treatment
effect you can integrate
over the modular treatment effects with
the weight here the weight will be one
if we integrate over the support okay
then you get the average causal effects
or the average treatment effect
and you can get the average treatment
effect on the treated
also by integrating the more general
treatment effect with an appropriate
weight
function
so all the traditional parameters that
we look at in causal inference
we can get them through this marginal
treatment effect
and more importantly suppose that
a policy maker wants to
induce people
okay
into college
in order to think that okay
maybe income is low we want to encourage
people to go to college so if we
induce 20 percent
okay of people who do not have a college
degree we use them to go to college
what would be the effects on earnings
right
so
usually if you look you use late or
every treatment defect
on the twitter only tweeted you may not
answer this kind of questions
which may be relevant for a policy maker
say that i want to induce
20 of people who are not fascinated to
get vaccinated what would be the fate of
such a policy on the outcome
okay
so there is a parameter called the
policy relevant treatment effect
parameter
that can help answer this question
through the marginal treatment effect
so that's why i think it's an object
that is not popular yet in statistics in
quantum physics but
it may help answer some questions
that are relevant for policy maker
questions
okay
so
here is an example just just a quick
question today so the identification of
the marginal treatment effect we require
a continuous iv right yes
so i'm going to come to that in terms of
when i state the assumptions
we need the continuous ib to be able to
say something for people here at the
margin otherwise you can you can only
identify the latest type
of
effect okay
questions yeah
yes uh i mean i think i i think i know
the answer screen but
of course once you have all these
marginals and you take these integrals
you can define things but take your
example
i have something that will get twenty
percent of the unbacked people who are
unvaccinated get vaccinated or 20 right
the exact shape of that of that
distribution is going to matter a lot
because you might
it might be the 20 percent are the ones
who are being careful anyway and so
there or you might have something else
that'll also get 20 but the right 20
percent
so you're assuming a lot of knowledge of
the exact shape of that distribution
yeah so
i i'm going to
look at the distribution of this pz
function and that will matter a lot how
many people are not treated how many
people are not fascinated or not i'm
going to show in the empirical example
the distribution and when i do this
exercise we're going to see
what are the people that are moving now
that are taking the treatment yes that's
important and that we play a role in
whether we are the affect that we're
estimating here the weight here actually
we depend on that
yes
but i think the question is a bit deeper
than that because the
uh if you define the part the prte right
so you want to extrapolate from a
particular the empty from a particular
group of people to another group of
people yes but this presumed that from
a set up to the other set up the empty
gonna keep the same shape
the empty function yes otherwise how you
could do the extrapolation when you're
gonna
do from one particular environment a to
the environment a prime
yes so but the assumption would be that
they have an instrument that do that
through the instrument right the
instrument does not shift
these uh
be here so that would be an assumption
that why the empty will keep the same
function so i i will assume that yes
under the scenario where i shift people
these instruments is not shifting but
the only thing that i'm changing would
be this policy
function the speed function yes
so
it is documented that in the u.s
more than the third
okay of the surveillance
respondent they claim to have a
professional degree why they don't have
such a degree
so if you think about measurement error
i'm going to introduce that so
it's a serious problem because of that
you may be getting
uh
an effect
that is not actually the causal effects
so it's important to cover measurement
errors
so but this this could be it could mean
two things right
just that people are misreporting
intentionally or just they don't
understand
the definition of professional degree
so we cannot say that people are
lying right it can be
both right
so okay the point is that there is
measurement error in survey data
especially when people
it's about like education or whether you
are fascinated or not whether you wear
mask or not right people may miss
reports because of social pressure right
so the assumptions okay we're going to
look at the assumptions and then the
identification results
the first assumption is that
we have an instrument that satisfies the
exclusion restriction
and this is pretty standard in causal
inference
the second assumption is what we call
extended random assignment
it states that the instrument is
independent of all the unobserved
variables in the model
right including the misclassification
variable
okay
so before the standard random assignment
will be that c is independent of y one y
zero d one d
zero
this d one star d zero star so here the
variable that
uh
drive the selection into treatment is
the b
so when this is independent of vc will
be independent of this star
one distal
okay
so because of this structure
i i only need my instrument to be
independent of this v
and then the potential outcomes
to get the standard randomness
assignment assumption but in addition to
that i'm going to assume that the
instrument is also independent of this
epsilon the misclassification okay
and then the second the third assumption
is that we're going to assume that the v
this course variable
okay
is absolutely continuous
so
we need that
if it's not continuous it's discrete
we we need that we know the support if
we want to look at the empty
so this assumption helps normalize the
distribution of v
to uniform 0 1 over the support if it's
not uniform 0 1
you can apply the c df of b on each side
here and then transform that to a random
variable that is uniform want okay
so this is just a normalization
now we need a continuous instrument that
default assumption
and why we need this i'm going to show
that in the proof but we needed to be
able to move the c in a continuous way
to be able to get the values for each v
question
and then the fourth assumption we're
talking about measurement error we need
to know something about the extent of
the measurement error
right
so
we're going to assume that we know some
upper bound
okay on the measurement error
if we don't know the upper bound we do
have no information then this upper
bound will be what one
can be from zero to one
but suppose that
i go to the universities and then i ask
them how many people
got the college degree they tell me then
i compare that to what i see in the data
say okay the difference can tell me
something about the extent of the
measurement error
right so we can have this extra
information from extra sources
okay
so this information we're going to take
it ad hoc and say okay we know something
about the
this the extent of the measurement if we
don't know then we're going to let this
alphabet to be equal to one
and i'm going to show you the bounds in
that case
okay
questions
so the identification result the main
identification results okay
so suppose that we take the conditional
expectation of y given this pc
okay we fix that
we're going to write it as the summation
of these two integrals the first
integral
is about the potential outcome for the
treated group
and second integral is about the
potential outcome for the untreated
group
okay
so what i'm going to do if i assume that
i have a continuous instrument and that
this is this function here is
differentiable
i'm going to take the derivative of this
left-hand side with respect to p
and then it's going to be equal to the
derivative of the right-hand side with
respect to p
right if i do that
you see that this part here
just gives
me
what i'm looking for
when what you're not with me if you take
the derivative of this quantity with
respect to p you get the expected value
of y one given v equal to p
right by definition you take this
derivative here you get the expected
value of
minus
y y zero given b equal to p because the
p is here
and that gives you the object that we
want to identify
right
so
if you look at this
if i knew this pz function
then i can estimate this i can this is
identified from the data
if there is no
misclassification
if there is no error in the
treatment variable
as i was saying
this pc function will just be equal to
the propensity score the probability of
getting treated given c
which we can estimate in the data we
know that we can estimate the frequency
score and then once i come here
also
once i come here
i point identify the marginal treatment
effect
and marginal as i was saying you see the
derivative usually we think about
marginal you see people are the merging
right so you have this derivative here
which is identified you get this object
and it can show you some heterogeneity
that you will not get through the
compliance average metaphase
so actually it's a function that you
identify
but now the issue in what i'm doing here
is that i don't know this pc function
because of the misclassification
so from now on what i will i will try to
do is how do i get this pc function
okay
if you give me a candidate for this pc
function
i'm going to check whether
this will be the
it will satisfy the restrictions that
the model imposed and keep that
so i'm going to try
find the possible candidates for this pc
function and that would be the
identification for the pc
okay
so how do we do that
let's look at this first
we go so from now on we try to get
identifies for the pz function okay
so let's look at this equation here
adjust from the law of total probability
take the unconditional distribution of
the v
okay you can split that
between people who misreport and people
who do not misreport just by using the
law of total probability okay
and then the second
equation here
comes from the first stage what we will
call the first stage regression if you
you're taking in terms of regression
here
okay
if you look at the first stage equation
you have this d star
equal to b less than or equal to p z
so if this star were observed that would
be my first page
right
so
we just use the first stage so we want
to identify an object from the first
stage so we use this equation
and then we solve for the
distribution of v
when the person is misreporting and
desperation of b when the person is not
misreporting
so we get these functions
now the question is are these two
distribution functions
not necessarily right so we need to make
sure that there are distribution
functions to be valid
and that gives us bounds on the pc
function
so we need this to be not decreasing
the limit at minus minus infinity has to
be zero percentage has to be one and
then the right continuity right
so if we use these conditions then we
get the following bounds on the pz
function
but these bonds are forgiven c
but now i'm
trying to look at the derivative
of this object with respect to p right
so i need the shape of the pz function
not only the location
right so i need more than getting point
wise bounds
on this pz function
right so from from that now what i'm
going to do i'm going to try to
identify
the slope
okay of this pc function not the
scale parameter not the location
parameter okay
so and then we write down the model what
is the information that we get from the
whole model the model that we have
we
have for
the general distribution of y d given z
that we can compute that from the data
then we are going to match that with the
unobservables quantities okay the
probability the joint probability of the
y one and the misclassification given v
okay plus this integral similar to what
we had in the beginning but now we
involve the y's
okay
i do the same thing for the reported
control group
there might be in the control group when
i see them but they are not necessarily
in the control because of
misclassification
and then there is another condition
which is called the index sufficiency
condition in this model
when you condition on the z
you get the same distribution
when you get you condition the pc
and that's similar to
rosemont reveals result that
when we think about ignorability when we
condition on x right
you get the same thing similarly if you
condition on the propensity score so the
piece is the propensity score here
so the model implies that
the distribution that you observe
okay you identify will be the same
distribution if i replace this d
by the propensity score
okay
so
these
three conditions they give us actually
the identifier set
for a pz
but as you can see this is
not tractable
so we are going to work out the
analytical bounds for the pz function
how we do that we are going to start
i say we want to look at the slope for
the pz right we're going to look at the
difference between pc
c and c prime for this quantity that we
observe in the data
this distribution that we identified in
the data we're going to take the
difference of c and c prime
when we do that
we get this this is kind of the density
version of what i just showed you we get
this the difference of these two
integrals the first integral involves y1
and the measurement error the
classification variable
and then the second part involves the y
0
and then the classification variable
okay
now we can apply the absolute value of
each side and then it going to be equal
but when i apply the absolute value here
i'm going to use the triangle inequality
it has to be less than the summation of
these two quantities
which gives me this
then i can integrate each side with
respect to with respect to y
okay
when i take this integral
then
you integrate this inside here with
respect to y you get the probability
that someone reports truthfully given v
and then on the other side you get the
probability that the person reports miss
reports given v
and the two sub up to one
you get the quantity now that only
depends on pz minus pc prime
and then this quantity has to be a lower
bound
on the difference between pc and pc
prime
so
pay attention to this a little bit we
want to identify
pc
which is an object from the first stage
regression
but now we can use information from the
second stage the y side
to try to bound an object from this
first stage usually we don't have that
right
this is like the
outcome variable is helping the
treatment variable in terms of
identification
usually dot updates so we create this
lower bound for the pc and pz prime
we're going to use
the pointwise bond to get an upper bound
and then the derivative that i showed
you is just a limited version when i let
c
go to z prime
right so that what we're going to do we
get bounds on the pc minus pz prime
then i'm going to take the limits
of these lathes for z prime to see
when i let c go to c prime so the
marginal treatment effect is like a
limits version of the local average
treatment effect
that's how we get the bounds on the
marginal treatment effect the analytical
bounds
okay
so this is
the main result we get if there is there
this extent of the misclassification is
zero there is no misclassification we
get
a limit of the late
okay
but if there is misclassification then
we get these two bounds
as you you can see we get the mean of
zero and something and the mass of zero
and something so we weakly sign
the modular treatment effect for hc
that's what i was saying earlier in
introduction
so you may get
this for a particular z but when you
integrate over to get delayed
you don't know the sign
that's why
sometimes with the modular treatment
effect you can see this heterogeneity
that otherwise you may not see with the
late
questions
so i'm going to show you some numerical
illustration and see
how the bounce
look okay
and
then from there i'm going to discuss the
assumption when the epsilon is
independent of v and when the epsilon is
not independent of v
okay here we don't have any assumption
for this bound there is no assumption on
the epsilon
except that the instrument is
independent of
everything that is unobserved in the
model
okay
so the in this design we know exactly
the pc function is just the
probability fee of 2z
okay
so and then we apply our bounds and we
have this
so
how informative are the bound it depends
on the extent of the misclassification
and also depends on the
how people misclassified how they
misreport
okay
so
as you as you can see here if the
misclassification is small
okay
the lower bound
is close to
the true value the true value is the
black one the upper bound sorry the
upper bound is the red one
and we can hit the upper bound depending
on the
dependence between the misclassification
and the cost variable v
but
if
the alpha the misclassification the
extent of music is equal to 0.5 in the
data
our bound
diverged so think about it this way
if everybody is misreporting
we can just flip the treatment and
control group and then identify the
parameter right
so on the two extremes we point identify
as you move far from the extreme and
then you get to the middle
then you have no information
850 percent of people in the data they
are misreporting
that's why the bond diverge
okay but now
how about it true
how about when you just ignore
that okay there is nothing
no misclassification in my data i'm
going to just ignore that and then
estimate the empty that's the derivative
of the expected value of y given the
probability score
so the green here
is just if you ignore the modulus that
there is misclassification in your data
and then you want to just estimate the
empty
usually the empty is not within our
bounds here and as you can see
in some extreme cases
you may be getting something completely
opposite of the sign
if you just ignore the misclassification
in your data
okay
so
how do we compare our result to the late
because we can do the same thing when we
are looking at the late the local level
treatment effects
okay
how we compare our bounds
so
a quick response to this is the modular
treatment effect what the late what has
been done the lower bound on
the pc minus pc prime is just this
submission half summation of these two
quantities
the bounds that i derive
but what we are getting here is the
maximum between the two quantities
so the max is always bigger than
we have summation unless the two
quantities are equal
so we have substantial improvement over
the existing bounds in the literature
okay
so
now what happens if just people are if
the misclassification is not done by
people for example
some administrative assistant is
reporting the results
there is just type in and then make
makes a mistake
so what happens to
that case
we still
have the same information can we tighten
the bond if we know that it's just
random
but if people are misreporting
intentionally
like okay
you go to the interview you tell the
manager that you have a college degree
and they have no way to check that then
that can influence your wage right that
they will give you because then in that
case the measurement error is not
differentiable in indigenous
right what happens in that case
so if the measurement is completely
exogenous we can just back out from the
first stage regression the pz function
as the function of the propensity score
that is reported
and the
rate of force negative and false
positive in the data
first positive means that
you don't have the degree but you report
that you have the degree
the first negative is that someone has
the degree
because maybe he doesn't want to show
that he's
smart
he just makes reports okay
so
in that case if the epsilon is exogenous
it's done by the administrative
assistant
then the first positive rate will be
equal to the first negative rate and
then it will be equal to the
misclassification rate in the data in
that case we say that the
misclassification is symmetric
okay
so in that case we're back to this so
the pc function that we are looking for
is that we divide up to these
misclassification rates
so when i change this misclassification
rate then
i get a set of functions
right that way i say i get this bound
when
we have this misclassification
depending depends on only on the extent
of misclassification
so
in this on in this picture what i have
is we know the true proportion of people
who misreport
and then we as a result
as a researcher we fix the alpha bar
we want to see what happens to the
identification so there is the true
misclassification rate
and there is what i set for my alpha but
the extent of the misclassification in
the data
okay
in the first week the alpha is equal to
zero and the alphabet is equal to 0.1
so we get this bound
on the
uh marginal treatment effect okay so
this is the identification instead of
getting this single curve we get a set
of curves but we still have informative
amounts
now we increase
the extent of the misclassification
the true one is 0.1 but instead we say
we don't know it and we say to 0.3 and
then you see that the bounce becomes the
bounds become larger
but now here what's happening is is
the true misclassification rate is 0.3
but we set our alpha bar to be 0.1
okay like we
we are restricting too much this extent
of the misclassification then we get our
identification
and
the true function
is not even within our identifier set so
it's a kind of sensitivity analysis
right
you play with this
extent of misclassification rate
but if you set it too low
you may under you may not cover the two
parameter
and are having the same mistake that
people will have if they just ignore
this classification
even if you are doing partial
identification
and if we set it correctly
0.30 it's similar to what we had here
we're getting the this bound
the the true one will come the lower
bound for the
modular treatment effects
questions
almost done almost done okay so i'm
going to show you
quickly i'm going to show some data i
want to
show you how you can save this in the
data so this is an application on
return to schooling in indonesia
so this is higher secondary school 10
plus 10 10 years plus
okay of education
so we look at the effect of that on
earnings
and as i said any people miss reports
when it comes to the education level
okay and
we first implemented the bound
okay the empty bound that that i showed
you assuming that there is no
misclassification what we get
we get this function here
okay
so here you can see this is like the v
variable the different values for v
and then you see that some people
people who face higher cost
the return can be negative
and people who face low cost
they can have positive return
but if i just take the average
i may not get anything i mean say there
is no
effect no return
but this heterogeneity you will not get
that if you did not use this empty
function
okay
now when we add misclassification to
that what happens
here we just had this single curve
which is decreasing when you add
misclassification to it and we assume
that the extent of the misclassification
is 0.1
we get this set of curves
okay that's partial identification but
still you can see that some people they
gain from
school
some people they lose
and some people they
in the middle
okay
if you just take the average you may not
see that
okay so since i don't have time
let me quickly conclude here
i want to say something about this
policy relevance like if we induce 20
percent of people
to get the degree what happens
so this is the question that is delayed
may not be able to answer right we did
that exercise here we say okay let's say
we get eight percent of people who
did not get the degree now we get them
get the degree what happens okay so we
see that if we move them and then they
get the degree the return will be
between
30 and 40
and i come back to the question that
he was asking before about this function
so if you look at
here people if we people who are here
they are the people who did not get the
degree much most people are here so if
we move 20 percent we are touching these
people right
so they have they face higher cost
that's why they do not get the degree if
you lower the cost
you may induce them and they will get
the degree right so we're changing the
distribution of the psd function
but we are assuming that the empty
function is still the same right but
we're changing the distribution we'll
move people from here to here and see
what happens to the return
okay
so
it's my turn
yes so okay let me conclude here so in
the paper we divide bonds that are empty
when there is misclassification
when you see someone in the treatment
group you really don't know when the
person is the treatment group or control
group just because they tell you okay
so we showed that if you ignore this
classification
you may have bias in your identification
if you identify the mt
but if you try to
take into account this misclassification
you lose point identification but you
can still derive some bounds that are
meaningful
so that's the
message here in the paper
thank you very much
thanks great talk so uh
two quick two a comment on the question
so um this step that you said where at
the end the information on the response
is informative about the distribution of
the treatments i think that's a very
interesting
thing that can happen and in for example
in the iv model it's partly how the
reason that you can
reject the the notifier assumption
essentially because uh the information
from the response lets you realize that
the assumption there no defies is not
possible and and that's
that's obviously tied up with the
situations where the the bulky pearl
bounds are more informative than the
natural bands because if there are if
they're
yeah because if you could have to if
there if there are notifiers then uh
that then they're going to agree um
a quick question here about the
yeah in this example what was the
instrument
the distance of courage
so yeah i didn't say it's the truth it's
not like uh what is saying it's
proximity whether you live in a corridor
or county you know it's the true
distance here
and yes it's you may still question the
validity of the instrument here
but we try to control for some observed
characteristics i didn't show here so we
abstract that from the treatment and do
some kind of uh rubin
projection we project out the covariates
and then use the residual to estimate
this curve yeah
excellent talk just a quick question uh
because i think it showed at some point
that there is a screen curve
corresponding to where you assume there
is no measurement error
that can fall out of the bound
does that mean in that case you can
falsify the assumption that there is no
measurement error for it for the data
set okay that's the good point
so
so this is
because i know the truth it's in the
simulation right i know the truth but
any data data through data i don't have
this i only can have my bound and i
don't have
any default oh okay so this is one you
know the misclassification yes so
basically it's like saying that
my bounds here right
the one that we derived here
this one
right
i if you know this classification you
point identify this as the
true
propensity score in the data
it can be
less than this quantity then yes but
it's the
it's the whole model you cannot say it's
just misclassification right it can be
the iv
right it can be one of these assumptions
right
so
yes the homework that i would say then
we can reject yeah so yeah which is
basically similar to the testable
implications in the late framework that
ismail they have
derived right yeah on the other hand i
feel it's a little bit surprising
because i think even if i assume the iv
model it seems to me that there's no
restriction of the instrument and the
act and the treatment so
oh okay
yes exactly
oh it's here
okay there is this sorry there is this
monotonous condition here
that is implicit in the model through
this specification
we impose the notifiers assumptions so
the threshold condition that he put here
and was not the first assumption
i have
quite a few too few questions i am not a
fan of the late type of parameter
because you know issa is not here
because she's also not a fan of the late
so my point is if you are really
interesting to the parameter like the
average treatment effect
and with type of misclassification right
so instead of looking at of bounding the
lathe that you do here is that possible
what looks like the bond on the harvard
shipment effect when you are in the
presence of missessification of the
treatment
so basically
you just use this right
this mount then you integrate over the
80 domain so how this is looks like
compared to the usual minsky
menstrual robin bonds
with misclassification with miss
classification this is a question
and the second thing is in presence of
miscasification do we get do we still
get the testable implication at allah
no
and in the presence of misclassification
that's the kind of question that he
asked in here
we have this
as testable application if we say okay
we plug in and say we ignore this
classification so it can be if i reject
this it can be either because of
misclassification it can be either
because of the iv set of assumptions
so the testable applications are similar
to
uh back and forth testing applications
that's why we cannot say
if it's misclassification or the ib
model
it's one of them
yeah i see the the last question that i
would like to ask is again going back to
my discussion with issa here so if when
you think about the
example that you give at the end you say
that if you induce people to have more
education how this is going to affect
the margin the yeah the decision but
when you do this experiment of
inducing people to have more education
are you keeping stable their potential
outcome
yes so that's the
but is that possible could you just push
people in an experiment to make people
more into the education and keeping
their level of ability the same so in
the mother that's a good point so in the
model we i assume that this one here
sorry
right so i said this is the benefit
function okay the interpretation
so it's kind of
try to change the benefits here
compared to the cost or try to lower the
cost right
if you think about the empty basically
it's like
people are the merging if i lower the
cost for them they may be able to go or
if i increase this benefit function they
may be able to go so
try to play with this
exogenously like you do type but not
trying to to touch the potential
outcomes
so that's the exercise i i don't know
what you mean
it's not possible to do this kind of
because if you think in the reality one
thing that you could do is for example
uh reduce college fees yes right and
something like that but if you reduce
cholesterol people gonna more invest
into their kid maybe this could increase
their ability people are going to
respond to that they will not keep fix
everything when you
move the college case or maybe having
more professor for example and having
more professors are going to affect
their ability and
so it is not clear to me that you could
just have an external esteem experiment
that's gonna change only my decision to
move or not but gonna keep all my
[Music]
other unobservable state
fixed or that laptop variable sheets yes
i i think i thought that when we do this
do calculus right we change it
exogenously my change when i lower the
college fees for them they do not have
nothing they have nothing to do with
that it's me as a policy maker all right
i said okay now
we lowered the college people every for
everybody for some people
but it's it's exogenous right it's not
that related to whether
you you come from low income family or
this you you do that exogenously let's
talk that during the break
okay let's thanks
[Applause]
you